the report author matt parr and good to
talk to you today the independent report
last summer did conclude that the met
was institutionally racist and
that the met had put up a huge number of
barriers to their report
why did you not find it to be
institutionally corrupt
well good afternoon um we found an awful
lot wrong with it let's be clear and
there's
huge areas of agreement between us and
the panel
and as you said in europe
uh the met's got an awful lot to do to
get its anti-corruption practices to
where they should be i think where the
slight difference was and bearing in
mind we had different remits
as we simply didn't see evidence that
the mistakes amit had made
were dishonest or were sort of
coordinated uh in a campaign to
frustrate the the panels uh work um we
saw lots of things that went wrong and
there are lots of things we criticized
and met for uh but i think without that
element of deliberate dishonesty uh it's
not a phrase that we'd use to call them
institutionally corrupt
that doesn't mean there isn't an awful
lot wrong and it's a very critical
report
well indeed and let's look at some of
those those things that are wrong uh the
mets employing criminals employing
people who've committed crimes why does
the police force do this
well i think every case should be judged
on its merits there might be occasions
where
someone who's had some sort of
transgression a few years beforehand
relatively minor should be allowed to
become a police officer uh we do think
that the mets tolerance for things like
that and their risk appetite as they
called it
is too high but where we're more
concerned is if you are going to take
somebody like that in and there might be
reasons to do so um it's a higher risk
and therefore you ought to monitor it
carefully and they ought to supervise it
more carefully and there's not enough
evidence of that going on uh
and in fact all sorts of degrees of
supervision of people who have
associations with criminals or have got
a checkered past
and nowhere near they ought to be
i mean why is this happening that that
these people are not then being
monitored once they're into the force
i mean like you i
sort of look at it and wonder how on
earth
after 35 years of criticism over
daniel morgan the way they handled the
initial investigation the subsequent
investigations the failures in court
in which police corruption was a very
major factor uh we find it uh
bewildering uh that no one seems to have
said this is something that we can't put
up with we've got to get it right uh
we've got to be absolutely sure over
this now
doing all the things that we've
recommended and recommended 20
areas for improvement
doing all those things doesn't guarantee
that you never get any corruption of
force but i think it's the minimum that
the public would expect is that the met
should be doing all it can to minimize
that and at the moment it just isn't
so you know essentially it almost seems
to what you're finding is that there
isn't sort of an institutional
conspiracy to be corrupt
but but there is corruption just by by
the fault of almost indifference
uh indifference is a word we use in the
report it's what it looks like to us uh
i'm sure the met will say differently
but uh there were low standards in the
way they looked after property which
again was a
feature with the exhibits of the daniel
morgan case there were poor standards in
the way they supervise people some of
their policies are not in accordance
with what the national guidance says
and there were just you know
people not doing the right things to
minimize the risk of corruption almost
across the board now there were some
pockets of real excellence so one of the
things we congratulate the met for is
that they had a big betting vetting
backlog they had 16 000 people unvetted
uh three or four years ago and they've
pretty much eradicated that and the real
high profile uh serious cases they
investigate those really well
but it's all the other things that they
ought to do uh to to make sure the wrong
people don't join the met and if they do
to make sure that they're found out and
they can't get away with corrupt
behavior it's all those little things
that they ought to be doing uh that that
on their own don't look as important but
in some uh they present a picture for us
of a force that doesn't really take it
as seriously as it should especially
after what's gone wrong in in the daniel
morgan case
what do you think it says about an
organization that they're not keeping
track of of warrant cards and how has
access codes for security things etched
on doors
yeah i mean it says something about the
culture of the organization doesn't it i
mean we've we've all seen these dreadful
uh cases where misogyny sexism racism
has
has blackened the met's reputation uh
but i think you know as an organization
you look at culture wider than that it's
it's how people behave when no one's
looking it's surely the first person to
see that there's this security breach
should pick it up and correct it uh
surely it's everybody should know that
if there's somebody who's got uh uh a
declarable association with somebody who
has to be related to someone who's an
active criminal
that should be supervised and people
should be aware and they're just not so
i think it speaks of an organization
that hasn't really got a grip
on this particularly important part of
police culture and practice
very interesting to talk to you thanks
very much for joining us there matt parr
h inspector of constabulary's carryouts
report into the daniel morgan case